DOL's are endangered wild dogs native to  india and they have a few hidden talents  [Music]  for one they can urinate while doing a  handstand with the impressive  but there but their survival depends on  their ability to work together on TV  [Music]  although they're no bigger than Border  Collies the hunting group is more than  the sum of its parts when their prey  seems to have escaped the initial  attempt one male pursues it  [Music]  on their own however they are much less  effective and their quarry escapes  the dole has been killed off for ages as  vermin and is suffering from habitat  loss and diseases brought by domestic  dogs sorry  domesticated domestic means not foreign  vetted or willful fix this later only  now are we coming to understand their  intelligence and intriguing lifestyles  like the aforementioned hand stampede  [Music]  [Music]